[Applause]
absolutely not yeah
oh I need a cigarette
it's Friday and you know what that means
yesterday was Thursday
so let's welcome tonight's guests this
southern belle puts enemies in deep
fried hell co-host of the bottom line on
Fox
the Army Corps of Engineers helped
design his mullet co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend and how's that your
favorite Awards
oh he is Tad not to brag but she also
has multiple indictments you
contributor cartoon
and finally even his biceps have biceps
my massive side everywhere
all right before we get to some news
stories let's do this
Greg's leftovers
don't you love this it's leftovers where
I read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it's my first time reading
these so if they suck I'll beat Joe
Mackey with a pillowcase full of oranges
until his face is unrecognizable and
they'll need dental records to identify
his body
here we go Justin Trudeau and his wife
are separating after 18 years
yeah it just goes to show the challenges
of an interracial marriage
hold on a second we have focused on his
face and not the thing to our left do
you see what do you see what's I've been
looking at Tyrus correct me that's a man
sticking his tongue out yes right I I
like I this is now a I we've been making
fun of this blackface photo for years
and just occurred to me there's
something else going on here that we've
totally totally ignored I never ignore I
always pay attention to the background
yeah because that's usually where the
Killer is yeah so in this case that was
what the creepiness was about to begin
you know what that explains the divorce
yeah all right let's move on shall we
um Detroit police found over a 100 cats
at the home of an elderly man after they
received complaints of a pervasive urine
smell
turns out it was the cats who called the
cops
[Laughter]
it's not our fault
Squad member Elon Omar appeared at an
event Tuesday night to celebrate her
State's legalization of recreational
cannabis and shared the story of the
time she got so high she married her
brother
just a joke although she never corrected
that this week a truck spill covered in
Arkansas Highway in nacho cheese
yeah too bad this didn't happen in
California they could have called chips
all right all right
shout out to Eric Estrada and John
Wilcox
Podge I know that singer lizzo is being
sued for harassing her plus-sized backup
dancers who allege she pressured them
into eating bananas protruding from
strippers vaginas
it's a shocking allegation that any of
them were eating fruit
[Applause]
the complaint also says lizzo was
reinforcing the worst stereotypes about
the plus-sized dancers when she should
have been reinforcing the stage
[Applause]
the chairwoman of the Somali Athletics
Federation is under Fire after her
unqualified niece lost a hundred meter
dash by 10 seconds
she's also Under Fire because it's
Somalia
that's how you tell a joke
during an episode of The View woopy
Goldberg detailed the challenges of
having sex in a pool
meanwhile her ex Ted Danson said their
relationship was a challenge trying to
avoid pools
Phil she says she prefers pools over sex
in the ocean because she doesn't need to
worry about anybody throwing harpoons
oh you know that's too far
that's too I disowned that but keep the
joke in because it's good dwarves in the
film industry are complaining about Hugh
Grant being cast as an Oompa Loompa in
the upcoming film Wonka specifically
that CGI has been used to enlarge
Grant's head In fairness he's more
famous for getting a little head
foreign
never forget the anniversary is coming
up never forget
after spending more than 14 Grand for a
custom-made collie costume a man in
Japan transformed himself into a dog to
celebrate his achievement he drank some
champagne out of a toilet
and he says the best part about being a
dog is that now no one cares what he
licks his own balls
a 33 year old woman broke the Guinness
World Record for the world's largest
mouth which prompted a special phone
call for Bill Clinton
[Applause]
the benefits of a mature audience
[Laughter]
finally a recently conducted survey had
asked people what makes the perfect
sandwich and the only correct answer is
a woman it's
[Applause]
a compliment
all right to the news Trump's support
enlarges after more bogus charges and to
support Trump is getting as Obama
sweating yep after another round of
indictments for everything from
obstructing proceedings to removing the
tags from mattresses
Trump's numbers just continued to rise
the more indictments and witch hunts the
greater his chances of winning the
Republican nomination for president a
Grammy an Oscar and an Emmy and
ultimately the White House in 2024 I've
done the math if he gets invited
indicted one more time he'll be more
popular than Barbie
and it's not just me saying it although
that would be enough reason to believe
it even Barack Obama is scared that
Donald Trump could win another term and
usually the only thing that scares
Barack is Michelle
in late June Obama reportedly had a
private lunch with Joe which is rare Joe
usually only eats lunch with a nurse or
people who want to bribe him
apparently Obama was pretty shaken up
telling old Joe he was concerned about
Trump's political strengths his loyal
following and a trump friendly
conservative media ecosystem Joe was so
alarmed there were a few moments when he
actually seemed to recognize Obama
laughs
and Obama said Trump could be a more
formidable candidate than many Democrats
realize he then said he had to get home
before Michelle notices he's gone
then you got the polls showing no sign
of the Trump support waning even mayor
Pete can't slow down this train
the latest New York Times Siena College
poll shows Trump widening his lead over
Ron DeSantis Ron is so distraught he's
thinking of sending himself to Martha's
Vineyard
54 to 17 among likely Republican primary
voters no one else even comes close but
that's only because yours truly hasn't
announced
no no no no
too many skeletons in this closet and I
mean real skeletons
and the cherry on top of Trump's best
week ever that Devon Archer hearing
detailing the Biden cam family
corruption remember that old thing it
happened five days ago but time flies
when the Democrats are indicting their
only Challenger over speech yeah talk
about timing it's about as coincidental
as a drug dog sniffing Hunter's luggage
and as Joe Pollock points out Trump's
first impeachment should be vacated
because the Dems violated the rules by
not allowing Republicans to call their
own Witnesses which may have included
Devon Archer not to mention the fact
that Trump was proven right on that
perfect phone call so while this spells
out Trump's best week ever the only
thing that could make it better is a
sale on self tanner and another two or
three indictments
laughs
Pete your mullet looks great thank you
uh you're well tanned you're uh I love
your boots and your little pocket square
uh everything about you is this a
critique yes should they vacate the
first impeachment I know they won't but
it seems like there's grounds for it it
certainly does and you talked about the
phone call the phone call was about
shouldn't you look into this Biden guy
yeah and these deals that they're doing
over there remember Trump was talking
about remember when he started saying
where's Hunter yeah I mean that was
early on I don't know where's Hunter
yeah and no one knew who Hunter was yes
was Hunter but he knew I mean inside it
was an Open Secret inside Washington DC
this was a dirty double dealing family
right and they and they found they
stumbled their way into him because
Obama chose him in South Carolina and
then he became their candidate they did
a bunch of deals when they think he
wouldn't be a candidate and now they're
stuck with him yeah and it when it comes
to Trump though what was it
investigation It's All Eyes
investigation impeachment indictment
wait until they imprison them wait if
you think his poll numbers are high now
try that that's where they want to go on
this inevitably yeah so it is it is a
good week for Trump for all the wrong
reasons yeah it's true we could have
talk about the greatest finale of any
movie ever Dagan the president gets
elected in jail and they have to come
and
they have to come and unlock him and
they and he goes I pardon myself
[Laughter]
he goes
what do you think
clearly like the more his adversaries
his enemies even his competitors go
after him the tougher and the stronger
he's getting it's like cosmically
they're in pumping him full of peptides
and human growth hormone and Mountain
Dew yeah all at the same time
and I just think about
if the soul adage you just wrote this
book show don't tell for this man to
March again into a courthouse and hold
his head eye high with fortitude and and
really rally not just the people who
support him but his family yeah and that
speaks more than his Republican uh
competitors who are like in the face of
adversity I will be really fierce when I
have to face her enemies
that doesn't saying that means nothing
seeing it says it all right and again at
least one of the republican nominees has
never stood up to a ham sandwich yeah
you're talking about the fact because
he's a vegetarian of course
he is you know cat I said once before
and I like quoting myself I know you do
yes the selection isn't between Trump
and Biden it's Trump versus the entire
political establishment the machine that
fixes everything from indictments to
impeachments to elections what say you
uh I think you my the same poll that you
cited with Trump and DeSantis to me the
thing that stood out the most was that
in a head-to-head between Trump and
DeSantis Trump got 22 percent even quote
among voters who believe he has
committed serious federal crimes yes
which is still bigger than the 17
DeSantis gets overall right
so they prefer a criminalized trump
didn't say for months that DeSantis is
not going to happen everyone keeps
trying to make him happen he's like Jeb
Bush 2.0
and that's exactly what's Happening Here
people want him to be a thing he's not
gonna he's not it sucks though because
he's a great governor and I think he got
too involved in the culture War stuff
man yeah I think people you know the
economy is an issue stuff like that he
got weirdly obsessed with the Disney
thing thank God I'm not like that yeah
next up trans attacks no kidding no
you're not
oh
Tyrus what do you make of this week
uh it's a it's a Bittersweet week uh I
think Joe Rogan who's not would never be
I would say framed as a Trumper yeah uh
talked about the how shocked he is at
what's going on and how it's making
people
support Trump that normally wouldn't and
that's the thing is the the mainstream
media wants us to all think that these
huge numbers are coming from his base
but it's not it's coming from people who
relate who see this who are tired of
this because whether you like him or not
he's changed things he's it's
transparent now now when we make jokes
about you buy one of Hunter's horrible
paintings and if you buy enough of them
eventually you or one of your kids who
never amount to nothing will get a job
at the White House an ambassador or
whatever like that's how it worked and
that was a microcosm that's how all the
things worked with China Ukraine Romania
it's the same thing you buy you give him
a big salary he tells me who paid and
then I will influence or give you jobs
for you that's that's how the whole
system works Trump didn't do that
because he came out saying I don't need
your money I remember when you tried to
give me money you tried to give me money
you still owe me money yeah so
and so he changed things so we're seeing
they're they're so hyped over him that
they're literally putting journalists on
the street corners like prostitutes
waiting for a trump car to go by yeah
they can get a look ah I mean it's
literally what it's come down to and all
that is all that is doing is galvanizing
everyday people who normally don't care
or like this is outrageous there was an
opportunity in this for the president to
be a president because if he was truly
concerned about the American people and
keeping democracy you have the trial
after the election what's the difference
what's it going to make yeah and if it
came out of Joe Biden's mouth but the
problem is it's not about getting him
convicted because they're going to get
one that's why there's so many the one
the two I'm concerned with is the one in
Georgia no one in New York because
they're they're not federal yeah so you
can't pardon those ones the other ones
that they could be pardoned but there
was an opportunity for him to say let
the people decide but he knows if we're
not talking about this
all his laundry with Hunter is all out
in the street and we all see it now and
the whole week confirmed it it's like uh
Devin Archer testimony indictment yep uh
plea deal falls apart indictment I mean
they're not even shy they're not even
hiding it anymore all right we got to
move on this looks like spray them
it was a two-for-one sale
[Applause]
whereas orange is the sign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else